[Music]
the maze runner director wes ball has
been working on a new planet of the apes
movie for several years as screen rant
reports disney is said to have not only
one movie but an entire trilogy in mind
for the franchise in 2011 rupert wyatt
in his film rise of the planet of the
apes laid the groundwork for a trilogy
which matt reeves continued with two
sequels in 2014 and 2017. the three
movies were critically acclaimed with
the visual effects and lead actor andy
circus particularly standing out it is
now being said that westball's new
trilogy will more or less immediately
tie in with the three films the script
for the first movie is already nearing
completion
according to deadline ball is even
backed out of the comic adaptation
harbinger for the production of planet
of the apes those behind the project are
still keeping quiet about both the
content and the release date however we
are very confident that we'll soon be
able to share more official news
in the past several spin-offs to the
popular hbo series game of thrones got
an announcement including the upcoming
series house of the dragon and other
spin-offs like the sea snake and 10 000
ships as we have learned in recent days
there are already plans for another
spin-off production which will
immediately follow the events of the
game of thrones main series according to
the hollywood reporter the focus will be
on none other than jon snow it is also
reportedly clear that kit harrington
will once again play the world famous
role although not all game of thrones
fans reacted to the news with great
enthusiasm the series will seamlessly
continue the storyline of the former fan
favorite many do see jon snow as a
likeable character compared to some
other game of thrones candidates however
his character is essentially quite
one-dimensional the series will likely
pick up directly after the events in
king's landing and show how jon snow is
sent back to the north further details
about the series as well as a release
date are not available at the moment but
we will keep you posted what are your
thoughts in the planned series about jon
snow and do you expect this series to
convince fans feel free to tell us in
the comments
the drama surrounding the flash star
ezra miller seems to have no end in
march of this year miller made big
headlines with his assault of behavior
on a couple in hawaii and his resulting
arrest back then warner brothers was
already in big trouble as the movie
giant has a rigorous policy when it
comes to such offenses see johnny depp's
role as grindelwald in the fantastic
beasts series as has now become known
miller has once again allowed himself to
engage in a scandalous action as
reported by u.s media miller was issued
with two restraining orders against him
within a very short period of time in
one case it is about him having recently
disappeared with the 18 year old
environmental activist tokata ironize
what is particularly juicy is that he
has known her since she was 12 years old
and is alleged to have provided her with
drugs in her teens the parents had a
restraining order against miller from
approaching the family police currently
remain on the lookout for the two
fugitives meanwhile miller mocked the
police chase on his instagram account
which has since been disabled even more
interesting is the case of an anonymous
mother from massachusetts who has also
filed an order against miller the case
involves the woman's 12 year old child
who is said to have been showered with
presents by miller in a creepy fashion
this has now definitely gotten warner
into real trouble and deadline reports
that miller will no longer be part of
future dc projects already in the wake
of the events in hawaii many fans
demanded the casting of grant gustin who
has already started the flash in the
series of the same name and has been
much better received by fans the only
thing warner is likely to lose with an
instant dismissal of ezra miller would
be an awful lot of money however that
might still be less expensive than
keeping up the hope of miller not
committing any more crimes either way we
are excited about what will happen next
with the flash so far the theatrical
release is still scheduled for june 23rd
2023
orcs are an integral part of the lord of
the rings the mostly vicious ugly
creatures have become a classic of the
fantasy genre much like the elves all
the more surprising then that amazon has
not yet published any proper footage of
the orcs for its upcoming the lord of
the rings series but as ign exclusively
presented on their site amazon now
shared six images of the belligerent
creatures one big difference to peter
jackson's movie trilogy is noticeable
right away the orcs shown here are
clearly more savage in appearance and
less organized this also seems logical
since the series is set in the second
age and thus well before the events of
the movies where the orcs proceed in a
much more coordinated manner under the
leadership of sauron and ceremon still
uncertain is whether we will finally
learn more about the origins of the orcs
in the upcoming series after all this is
still a big mystery we are looking
forward to further news about the lord
of the rings the rings of power and we
cannot wait for the streaming premiere
on amazon prime video on september 2nd
2022
slowly but surely denivel new sequel to
dude is getting underway while last
month we were already able to report on
the signing of christopher walken as the
infamous emperor chatham iv another
top-notch cast member has now been
announced we are talking about 36 year
old leah sedu who played the role of
madeleine swann and james bond no time
to die according to deadline she has
already been chosen for the role of lady
margot in the upcoming dune 2. in the
novel by frank herbert she forms part of
the bennie jesseret and is considered an
ally of the ruling atritus family she is
also closely connected to the story of
fade rautha a nephew of the evildoer
baron harkani filming of dune 2 is due
to start this fall so it's not to cause
any delays to the theatrical release
date of october 20th 2023
from june 13th to june 18th the nc
international animation film festival
took place again this year the grand
highlight was certainly an announcement
by paramount to nickelodeon as they
announced the production of not one but
three new animated movies based on
avatar the last airbender the mention
was of a theatrical run so after all
these years we can finally expect a big
screen release in terms of content not
much is known yet but there should be a
prequel about kyoshi a film about prince
zuko and another one about avatar korra
the latter is to be said at the end of
the animated series the legend of korra
which aired on nickelodeon from 2012 to
2014 however this information should not
be relied upon too much since it's only
a matter of rumors so far series
creators brian konietzko and michael
dante di martino are both involved in
the production which should be a good
sign in addition lauren montgomery who
also worked in the original series was
convinced to direct the first movie we
are eager to see how the responsible
parties will bring the movies to life
and look forward to further details by
the way netflix is also currently
producing the live-action series avatar
the last airbender which is likely to be
released by the streaming service at the
end of this year or early next year
a few weeks ago we were presented with
the first image of the upcoming barbie
film adaptation it showed margot robbie
in the titular lead role and it has to
be admitted that this is exactly the
kind of pink and fancy live-action
portrayal of the toy doll we had hoped
for now a picture of barbie's admirer
ken who was played by ryan gosling came
next the 41 year old shows himself with
a well-toned upper body a denim vest ken
underwear and peroxide blonde hair he
thus comes pretty close to his original
as well however the film is about much
more than the plump serving of cliches
despite the fact that the two published
images suggest otherwise after all it
should not be forgotten that greta
gerwig is a director who has so far
emphasized strong women beyond the
classic gender roles in her films
examples of this include lady bird and
little women which were both nominated
for several oscars there's still little
information about the plot but we do
know the movie revolves around a large
toy company which to all appearances is
modeled on the barbie manufacturer
mattel in addition many actors praised
the excellent script which was written
by director gerwig and her husband noah
bomback in general the movie has a
pretty impressive cast among them
besides the two main actors robbie and
gosling there are will ferrell as the
potential ceo of the toy company michael
cera america ferreira kingsley benadir
issa rae kate mckinnon and many others
barbie will be released on the big
screen in nearly a year on july 21st
2023
that were the latest news of the week in
case you're looking for more content you
should not miss our new original on the
transformers franchise there you will
learn about the origins of transformers
while getting a great recap of the whole
movie series as well this will hopefully
evoke some nostalgia in you and make you
look forward to the seventh installment
called rise of the beasts set for
release next year have fun watching
[Music]